hello, everyone, yes, I'm going to talk about
real‑time in the browser, XMPP I'll try
to keep it quite light, if you feel like me,
you're a bit frazzled and tired.
Okay, so ...
XMPP it's the externsble messaging and presence
protocol.
And this was developed back in 1998.
A time when people had lots and lots of different
IM clients you had AOL messenger, yahoo messenger,
ICQ and you would here Eh‑oo every couple
of minutes.
It was a bit of rubbish situation, some friends
on one, another set on another one, you'd
either have to run them all or ignore some
friends‑‑ it was a bit of a crap situation.
So, some guys got together and they thought
what we'll do and we'll build a system where
you can have lots and lots of different servers
but they'll all be able to talk to each other.
It was originally built as an application
called Jabba, but since it's changed to XMPP
when it became part of the ITF.
And it's not a single server or single piece
of code, it's a set of standards, so anyone
can implement it, you can have proprietary
servers, Open Source servers, and there's
lots and lots out there.
The big advantage of it is it's forked rated
all the servers can talk to each other without
any extra coding.
(Fedder rated) who here uses the XMPP? Okay.
Keep your hands up.
That's not right.
Okay.
So, who of you here uses WhatsApp, yeah, that's
a few more.
It's basically a hacked version of XMPP they
just used some of the bad bits and not some
of the good bits.
Who here uses Facebook chat? Yeah, okay.
Who here uses Hip chat, okay,cool, so you're
all using XMPP.
I think maybe two or three people that didn't
put their hand up.
So who here has a smartphone? Yes, see you
all use XMPP, you just don't know about it.
It's widely use in the areas of finance, government,
a lot of messaging systems, companies that
do building management use it a lot.
My point is it's often not advertised that
it's being used.
Why do I think XMPP is important? Well, we're
seeing the continuing growth of real‑time
on the web, you see people bringing up new
real‑time systems quite often and you watch
how it goes and they just keep making the
same mistakes that were solved in XMPP about
twelve to fourteen years ago, you see them
try to add things like it would be cool if
you could run it on multiple servers the and
talk to each other and they do this hacky
piece of crap, these are problems already
solved with XMPP.
People shouldn't keep making the same mistakes,
the other area where it's quite interesting
as well is with the rise of webRTC, peer to
peer sessions all greet, but there's no signal
in webRTC, how did you find each other? The
way it's done currently people use meet me
URLs, you is to agree to some terms on a website,
maybe tracked, maybe this system doesn't have
all the features you want, this one does,
and your friends don't like that one, why
do that when you can both log into an account
and share the details directly? And there's
also movement back towards this sort of decentralized
web so the Snowden revelation, big targets
like Google, Apple Facebook, it's easy for
people to request information.
If we're running smaller servers and smaller
groups, actually to get information about
what you're up to is a lot more difficult.
And then the last point is, if you also use
XMPP you don't just get some chat messaging
stuff, you get things like presence, which
I'm available right now, I'm away, I'm busy,
you get address books, pubsub, you get peer
to peer session seat up, you get tons and
tons of stuff for free without any extra work.
Lets quickly go through some of the fundamentals
of XMPP.
Stanzas, they're just chunks of XML, there's
three basic Stanzas, one of them is message,
which is just sort of chat messages, sending
updates.
The second is presence, which is basically
I'm on‑line, I'm off line, there's a really
cool feature called priority, which I'll talk
about in a second, and the third one is IQ
or information query which has set and get,
basically like you have very simple HTTP‑‑
then there's also the JID or the Jabber ID
consists of three parts first you is your
server, so in this example it's example.org,
I then log in as user@example.org.
And I then have this third thing on the end
called a resource, which is really interesting,
even though this was designed back in 1998,
it was designed with multiple devices in mind.
Going back to the presence Stanza I talked
about a second ago.
I'm on my laptop work away my laptop has a
presence priority of 5.
And when people send messages to my user@example.org,
messages get routed through to my laptop.
When I walk away from my laptop and have my
phone, which has been happily sitting there
at a priority of four, the laptop goes to
sleep drops down to a priority of one, and
now it will get routed to me on my mobile
phone, so you can always be sure the messages
get the device that the person is most likely
to be using.
Clients.
What we say with XMPP is that your clients
should be very, very light.
And this is really good for mobile phone usage
because we don't expect the clients to do
any work whatsoever.
You save a lot of battery that way.
You connect to server in three different standard
ways of connecting, one is just a standard
socket, the other one is a long poling set
up and the new one is the web sockets.
And the other thing that's really good, unlike
other systems which pole a server to do real‑time,
that's quite heavy on your server and your
clients, setting up new connections is there
any information, no, thanks great! So it's
very intensive, where as with XMPP data gets
pushed, so, if you imagine kids sat in the
back of the car, are we there yet, are we
there yet? Are we there yet? In this case
we say just shut up and I'll tell you when
we're there.
Very different.
Servers, all they're there for is to route
messages, they set up these secure connections
between each other, and they handle the authentication.
And then the third part is the components
which is pretty much where you develop is
going to to be held, so the server custom
business logic, you can have standard components
or you could do something specific to your
use case.
And a nice way to build components in JavaScript
is to use node-xmpp-component. They're server
agnostic, so I could write my code in JavaScript
and connect to a server in lua and then get
rid of the server and replace with Java server
and I don't have to change anything about
my code.
All right, so why don't we see it being used
by web developers? Well, the big advantage
X M L is the extensibility part but the big‑‑
in order to achieve that extensibility we
use XML, I don't know about you guys, my interactions
with XML has been via soap, it's horrible,
not nice to deal with in the browser, it's
slow you can sometimes lose data and things
like that.
And also when you compare it to JSON XML seems
verbose, ugly, and old fashioned, it's just
Yuck.
So what I've done is created a library called
XMPP for the web. It converts messages to
JSON on the server. And then send it down
to your over web socket.
And this makes it much nicer to develop applications,
using XMPP but not be exposed to any of the
nasty stuff as web developers we don't really
like.
So what I'm going to do now is probably get
this completely wrong, this will be the funny
part of the talk. ..
I'm going to do a live demo and show you how
easy it is to build an application.
I'm going to ask you to help me out, so it's
a part participation exercise.
I'm going to write a little application here
and what it's going to do is listen for incoming
chat messages, draw a little circle on the
screen and allow you whys guys to move it
around.
But the interesting bit here is you're all
going to connect on servers all around the
world and and they're going to talk to my
server and perform the actions, so if you‑‑
that UL, in the meantime I will start coding
up something (If you pop open that URL, in
the meantime I well start coding something)
so I'm just going to drop this over here.
Okay, the first thing I need do is log into
my server, so let's get that done.
So all I have in this, very much like the
clients you'll be loading is an MD5 library
because a hash of a string is 0‑9 A‑F
take the first six characters gives me a nice
Hex colour code, Jquery and web socket being
delivered for XMPP for the web.
Okay, so
that's listening for my incoming connection,
I'm going to ask it to log in for me.
For any of you about to get excited, Ha‑Ha‑Ha.
Okay, cool, all right, I'm on‑line, I'm
connected.
I can start doing nice things, so when I was
talking about the JID just now you'll see
that I'm connected as lloyd@buddycloud.org,
I could ask for a specific resource but didn't.
Buddycloud is distributed social network that
I work on. You should check it out, it's cool
to play with.
Okay, so, next thing, I need to draw circle
on the screen when I get new connections,
What I'm going to do is hash the incoming
JID.
Do‑Do‑Do.
So if I already have it, obviously I don't
want to draw again ...
otherwise I'm just going to draw myself a
nice little circle.
I also have some CSS which will handle the
circle part.
And what I'll do in here as well is I'll draw
up an identifier.
Okay, and what I'll do then, in order to show
you the fact that you are connecting from
different domains, I'll change the border
colour of the circle to a hash of the domain
that you're on.
Okay.
Sorry, I should of got some music for this
really, shouldn't I ...
and lastly, actually I'll just leave that.
Cool, all right, so I have my draw function,
next thing I'm going to listen for a chat
message, promise you won't be too much longer.
socket dot on‑‑ actually first of all,
I need the tell the server I'm on‑line,
I may be connected but I haven't told it when
I receive update .
Let's say to the server, I'm on‑line. Cool,
I'm on‑line and I want to receive updates.
Okay, so socket.on XMPP.chat.message, this
will pass through a nice message, which is
just the content and who sent it to me, so
let's go ...
First of all we need to draw a circle ...
and then we just need to listen to what you've
said to me and just shift your circle about,
so if I create the hash again‑‑ okay‑‑
if we want to go up, we will pick up no, it's
minus equals and we'll just shift it by ten
pixels.
Cool anyone actually logged into the client?
Everyone logged in okay? Yep, cool.
Okay.
Up ... down. We'll just add ten Pixels.
We're going to right where right, head left‑‑
now, hopefully, Oooh, look, someone's already
there.
If you guys want to start shifting, I'm guessing
it's not actually ...
I'm guessing I've got this wrong ... Okay,
in the UK we have a show called Blue Peter
who if when they build something they always
have the line "Here's something we made earlier".
There we go, that's moving on the screen if
all the different servers, it may be a little
bit of lag because I am connected to a server
on the east coast of the US that's connected
to my XMPP which is in Munich which is then
connected to a server somewhere in the world
depending on which one you guy haves connected
to that then connects to the server on the
east coast of the US then comes back to Berlin
to talk to you, it's going a long way.
But as you can see, that's‑‑ throwing
things from many different servers, Polish
servers, British servers, French servers,
American servers but they're all talking to
my server in Munich without any additional
code.
In summary, XMPP is a secure, scalable real‑time
messaging system, it's scalable because when
you get a thousand users, rather‑‑ or
tens of thousand users, you don't just, you
know, cluster or get more servers, you just
create a new domain, so it's very scalable,
it's really‑‑ it's essentially really
easy way to help rebuild a de‑centralized
web and you get a lot of extras for free.
Wanted to keep it very light, hope that was
okay.
Thanks very much (Applause)